hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
mit Murat
[Musik]
unglaublich
Jahresrückblick 2022 da sitzen wir schon
also hätte mich jetzt jemand gefragt wie
lange ist Silvester her hätte ich gesagt
so ja mein Gott da war mir gerade erst
für 5 Monate
waren sehr sehr turbulentes Jahr muss
man ganz ehrlich sagen für uns ich denke
mal für euch auch alle für alle auf der
Welt was ich bin mir auch fast sicher
dass sie das Mehrzahl der Menschen froh
ist es ja nicht ich glaube auch weil
also viele haben jetzt schon so ein
bisschen Postings gemacht und
geschrieben 2022 Gott sei Dank bist du
vorbei viele haben gesagt das war so
noch mal das zweite 2020 und 21
aber ich muss sagen egal was man erlebt
man lernt immer was draußen hoffe ich
ähm man erlebt was und vielleicht muss
man ein bisschen mehr das Bewusstsein
dafür haben dass man es halt auch
genießt aber ich muss auch sagen ich bin
froh dass dieses Jahr vorbei ist aber
ich bin trotzdem immer für alles dankbar
dass wir dieses
wobei wir sagen müssen das hat schön
angefangen wir waren ja weiß noch wo wir
waren Silvester letztes Jahr wir waren
es Silvester letztes Jahr waren wir wie
immer daheim nein ich habe es auch kurz
gedacht weißt du Türkei ja ach stimmbild
das zweite Mal das Silvester in der
Türkei verbraucht super schön
und danach waren wir hier und hatten
eigentlich direkt eine Reise was ganz
besonderes
erste Mal einen Lappland ein Ort wo ich
niemals gedacht hatte dass ich in meinem
Leben jemals dorthin gehe weil ich mag
kalte gegen den eigentlich nicht so muss
ich ganz ehrlich sagen aber es war ein
Traum und es war ich würde mich mein
Leben lang daran erinnern das war so
eine andere Kälte das war also wir haben
ja wir haben so einen Cheat bekommen so
eine Liste was wir alles besorgen müssen
für die Reise weil man da jetzt nicht
einfach Koffer packen und hin denn in
Lappland hat auch teilweise minus 40
Grad und wir haben dann so Minister
bekommen Skiunterwäsche Skikleidung dies
und jenes und haben das noch alles
besorgt und waren dort und es war echt
schön es war alles noch gestellt
bekommen also wenn es gar nicht kaufen
müssen ja stimmt ja stimmt
zurückgebracht und und habe da noch mal
aber es war richtig schön wir haben
Polarlichter gesehen wir waren
Eisfischen wir waren mit Huskys auf so
einer Schlittenfahrt wir haben in so
einem schönen Häuschen geschlafen was
oben so eine Kuppel Dach aus Glas hatte
und da konnte ich quasi die die ganze
Nacht immer beobachten und wir hatten
doch nur wie viel Stunden Tageslicht
oder vier nur vier Stunden
ich war schon ein bisschen schon 15 Mal
in der Türkei bestimmt schon
wahrscheinlich sogar schon mehr aber ich
kann mich manche Urlaub in der Türkei
nicht mehr erinnern weil es eigentlich
immer irgendwie das gleiche war aber an
diesen lapplandurlaub ähm werde ich
nicht mein Leben lang erinnern ich mir
ganz ganz sicher deswegen ist es wichtig
dass ihr auch öfter mal irgendwo das
hingeht damit ihr einfach lebt und es
nicht vergisst und also es war für mich
ich will jetzt kein zweites mal hingehen
muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen wenn ich
dann wenn ich ich habe aber gemerkt ich
will noch mal so etwas erleben wo ich
mein Leben lang nicht vergesse aber wir
waren eigentlich auch nur vier Tage zu
sagen also es hat sich angefangen mit
wunderschön es war so toll aber ich
würde gerne noch mal hin weil wir die
Kinder nicht dabei hatten und da gibt's
auch so Nikolausdorf und einfach ist es
einfach wunderschön deswegen irgendwann
werden wir es noch mal erleben
vielleicht war es auch Wasser vielleicht
schön wenn die Kinder nicht dabei sind
ich bin mir nicht mehr dran erinnern
kann
[Musik]
ja jedenfalls war das so unser Start ins
neue Jahr und dann haben wir in diesem
Jahr eigentlich ganz groß noch mal
kitchen gespielt
ganz krasses Format bei wir haben da
eigentlich für nur drei Tage eingeplant
weil wir immer so getaktet sind an drei
Tagen fertig bekommen aber die magischen
Formate down wirklich anscheinend 10 bis
15 Tage
und es ist so krass mit dem Wissen von
heute würde ich heute nicht mehr machen
aber wenn es so Spaß macht Willis dass
ich so oft wie möglich machen also
eigentlich war ja der Plan dass wir 2021
6 mai kitchen Folgen machen wollten da
sind wir damit gestartet und ich dachte
halt so gerechnet hier und da dann die
Planung klar so eine Woche kriegen wir
alles durch mit Dreh mit Wohnräumen mit
allem nichts da pustekuchen das hat uns
schon ziemlich viel Kraft und Energie
gekostet deswegen haben wir 2021 zwei
Folgen geschafft und dieses Jahr auch
zwei Folgen weil wir das halt auch alles
alleine machen ich meine wir produzieren
das hier mit meinem Kamerateam wir haben
keinen Redakteur kein Regisseur das
machen alles wir haben die ganzen ganzen
Einbau Hilfe aber es ist wirklich
saumäßig viel Arbeit aber es ist ein
ganz tolles Format und ich kann mir noch
einen kleinen Klaus erinnern und der
kleine Klaus der war so genial den Junge
der jeden Tag gerne hier das ist mein
richtiger Kumpel geworden
[Musik]
okay ich würde sagen wir gehen jetzt
alle gemeinsam rein und machen die Küche
schön ja
wer hat Lust dazu super
also kommt
neue Küche
[Musik]
Lippenstift
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
richtig schön ich liebe es auch Küchen
zu planen Küchen einrichten organisieren
Küchen aufpimpen also ich werde auch in
diesem Jahr bei einigen Freunden und
Bekannten noch mal die küchenschubladen
aufräumen weil immer wenn ich die öffne
denke ich mir so kann man was optimieren
uns macht mir halt auch Spaß und was
ganz krasses bekommen von ganz viel
Promis inzwischen die Anfrage also sehr
sehr viele Promis schreiben uns an und
sagen hey ich baue gerade und ich ziehe
gerade um und Sally ich vertraue dir
kannst du vorbeikommen und die Küche
einplanen das heißt da werden wir dieses
Jahr noch einiges auch machen und es
kommt auch die Community Küche das heißt
Zuschauer oder Zuschauerin hat eine
Küche gewonnen und bekommt eine und die
werden wir überraschen ja da sind wir
gerade an der Feinplanung tatsächlich
das erfahrt ihr dann aber alles im neuen
Jahr da gibt's doch ganz ganz so eine
Seite die heißt kitchen.de da könnt ihr
mal die ganzen Folgen noch anschauen und
vor allem was wir da verbaut haben
schaut euch das an ganz ganz wertvolle
Seite
ja letztes Jahr war auch der Start von
raspberry also hättest Du mich gefragt
dann hätte ich gedacht raspberry gibt es
schon seit zwei drei Jahren aber nein
wir arbeiten zwar seit zwei drei Jahren
an unserer gartenmarke aber richtig
gelauncht haben wir sie letztes Jahr
[Musik]
schatz was ist Schwerin
war auch kein leichtes Video es war ein
bisschen knifflig aber ich glaube wir
haben es ganz gut hinbekommen außerdem
haben wir das Intro nachgemacht und das
war super
[Musik]
Eingang stand
von diesem ganzen Video es war so cool
mit Günni und Murat
einfach bei den beiden Verordnung
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
ja dann war es letztes Jahr soweit 2022
und es gab auch hier im Team immer mal
wieder einige Dinge die umgeschmissen
werden mussten neu improvisieren und ich
muss echt sagen dass ich so ein krasses
Team habe da ist wirklich nicht so dass
einer sagt okay ähm die Person hat
irgendwie nicht alleine geschafft und
man lässt die Person hängen sondern da
zieht echt jeder an einem Strang und ähm
viele sind eingesprungen und haben uns
ausgeholfen und es war ein wahnsinniges
Team Projekt und raspberry ging an den
Start aber muss ich sagen es war ein
schwerer Start es war ein schweres Jahr
also man kann man Luca vielleicht auch
mit reinnehmen wenn man Luca am
raspberry waren ganz schwierige Star
rausgekommen hat jahrelang gearbeitet an
beiden Projekten und dann haben wir
dieses Jahr wirklich alles beide
gelaufen Manuka und raspberry auch zwei
völlig verschiedene Marken aber es ist
ein Marken die uns selber berühren also
Garten ist so ein geniales Thema mit
raspberry ist immer relativ spät
gestartet eigentlich schon nach der
Saison weil die Saison im Garten ist
eigentlich März bis Juli kann man sagen
wir sind irgendwann Ende Juli gestartet
also morgen schon vorbei war und wir
haben da so viel Manpower reingesteckt
und so viel
Emotionen und so viel Arbeit die
Produktion gemacht haben sind gigantisch
der Boden Aktivator die Liquids die
Kleidung wo wir gemacht haben Werkzeuge
die Wirkung ja was wieder alles gemacht
haben das waren sehr holpriger Start
muss ich ganz ganz ehrlich sagen aber es
ist nicht schlimm man lernt aus allem
und jetzt ist es neue Jahr und ich weiß
ganz genau starte demnächst und es wird
richtig toll und vor allem haben wer hat
gesagt war 2022 echt schwer für diese
zwei Marken aber wir wollen jetzt im
neuen Jahr einfach gestärkt und
motiviert daran weiterarbeiten es muss
auch nicht immer man muss auch nicht
immer immer nur Erfolge feiern das ist
ganz ganz wichtig man lernt nicht außer
Folgen man lernt aus Niederlagen und man
lernt aus Fehlern das heißt Fehler zu
machen das meint was nicht funktioniert
das ist auch was tolles man lern raus
und und geht gestärkt heraus vor ja bei
Manuka haben wir zum Beispiel ganz stark
gemerkt Manuka war ja ursprünglich nur
eine Kindermarke und dann haben wir
gesagt ach komm minimilux werden cool so
Hoodies für Mamas und Papa ist und dann
für die Kinder mit dazu und da war
eigentlich gemerkt dass mehr
erwachsenenkleidung tatsächlich auch
gekauft wurde und viele mehr daran
Interesse haben
echt das war eine kinderkleidermarke
Medien Germany äh Kinderkleidung von
Erwachsenen produziert für Kinder und
nicht von Kindern und ist das in
Pfullingen produziert das Medium
Germanys waren extrem wichtig oder war
es eigentlich so dass die meisten
Erwachsenen Kleidung gekauft haben ich
glaube tatsächlich auch und das wird
vielleicht auch das Feedback der
Community sein ich glaube wir hatten
dieses Jahr irgendwie so immer würde
sagen Pfeffer im Hintern wir haben so
viele Projekte gemacht so viel anstatt
gemacht ich habe viele kam gar nicht mit
also die kamen nicht mit was ist jetzt
raspberry was ist Manuka was ist die
Firma
das war einfach vielleicht auch ein
bisschen und dann müssen wir einfach
vielleicht so nicht in Gang zurücklegen
aber so ein bisschen anders
dementsprechend möchten wir nächstes
Jahr auch wirklich muss ich ganz ehrlich
sagen auch etwas weniger machen
Zusammenschnitt machen aus jedem
Jahresrückblick weniger machen ja ein
bisschen weniger Familie und freut
sich auf dem Projekte die wir 2021
angehen werden also es wird wirklich
wieder ein turbulentes Jahr das ist
dieses Jahr ein bisschen
entspannter
ich freue mich schon aufs nächste Jahr
weniger aber es ist einfach morgen
wieder den nächsten 100 Ideen das macht
einfach Spaß es ist man geht darin auf
die Leute motivieren ein die Leute die
arbeiten motivieren die Zuschauer ihr
wenn ihr uns schreibt hey das ist so
toll hey der Bodenaktivator mein Mann
sind die Haare gewachsen lauter solche
Sachen aber so lachen müssen als Mann
krassesten Sachen also mal schauen ja
mal gucken jedenfalls war dieses Jahr
für uns aber auch ein Jahr der
Meilensteine
doch da werde ich wieder emotional
dieses Jahr war unsere zehn Jahres Video
ja 10 Jahre so schön das war ein sehr
schönsten Videos was ich bekommen habe
weil es
weil es für uns so war dass wir die zehn
Jahre die wir bisher erlebt haben
irgendwie so wir haben keine
Meilensteine gefeiert wir haben die
reflektiert nie zurückgeblickt und zehn
Jahren nicht genossen das ist ein
Problem weil du hast ein stetiger
Wachstum es wird immer mehr es immer
mehr und man vergisst diese
Kleinigkeiten und das Schöne im Leben
sind diese Kleinigkeiten diese kleinen
Momente wo man vielleicht nicht als
großansatz anschaut aber dieses diese
kleine glücklich sein und das haben wir
sehr sehr oft verpennt muss ich ganz
ganz ehrlich sagen zumindest dieses Jahr
geschafft das war gesagt haben
Meilensteine werden gefeiert genau vor
allem alle Menschen die im Video
gesprochen haben das sind Wegbegleiter
die seit kurzem was dabei sind oder Weg
begleitet die schon seit über 10 Jahren
dabei sind und das Video war eines der
emotionalsten schönsten Videos die ich
je bekommen habe das war einfach schön
[Musik]
sie hat gedacht wir machen dann
Zusammenschnitt so von den zehn Jahren
aber ich glaube mit dem Video hat sie
nicht gerechnet das war so schön wie wir
dann alle zusammen Valley waren alle
haben drauf gewartet Serverprobleme
ich war nur ich war
also bei so einem großen Event
noch
angerufen okay Anna okay Anna passt
jetzt geht's jetzt online und nicht so
ja ja ist online aber es hat nur nur so
so Schwierigkeiten wie beim Server und
er ist okay dann mach's aber gleich
online und so war die darf ich auch noch
rüber Rennen bevor es los
die kommt schon noch
[Applaus]
das war witzig wie wir uns da versteckt
haben hinter den Autos
und dann kam so und wir waren alle voll
aufgeregt
ich finde das voll cool
ich mag so ziemlich Sachen
verlegen dieser Mashup einfach aus super
vielen Liedern voll viel Variation drin
wir konnten nicht Proben also habe ich
mich zu Hause hingestellt Videos gemacht
von vorne und hinten und in die Gruppe
reingestellt und da waren alle zu Hause
manchmal
vor Ort einfach gemacht
und dann waren die ich im Valley drüben
und haben
halt hier drüben gedreht für Shopping
Queen und oben haben die Jungs und
Mädels Mittagspause gehabt und haben sie
geprobt und dann haben die geprobt und
ich hatte die ganze Zeit Angst dass
Sally das trampeln von oben hört überall
getrampelt
aber der müsste doch überrascht
richtig überrascht
ja mach mal zehn Jahre Youtube oder zwei
Millionen Abonnenten da kriegst du das
auch ja ich bin ja 50 Jahre ich da hätte
man sowas schon mal machen können
und dann hat sie direkt geheult ich war
vorne musste auch fast am Anfang hat die
Musik funktioniert das verwirrt aber
sonst hat es alles richtig gut geklappt
und aber das beste war ja wie sie
einfach am Ende noch mal mitgetanzt hat
ey das ist der Wahnsinn wie die einfach
das so schnell
aufgesogen hat und den Tanz einfach
konnte es sie hat nicht mal einmal
geprobt und dann kannst du aber es
wundert mich eigentlich wundert mich
nicht aber
noch die zwei Millionen geknackt 2
Millionen Abonnenten auf Youtube als
food Channel das ist schon immer noch
eine Nische ist also man tut ja nicht
OMA Pranken oder Fürze anzünden oder
oder irgendwas ja oder in Chicken Wings
Baden es gibt viele Videos wo man
anschaut Klassen unterhalten aber haben
keinen Mehrwert und macht mir etwas mit
education finde ich man bringt Menschen
was bei man zeigt wie man Koch wie ein
Backen immer baut und bastelt und
deswegen hat zwei Millionen Abonnenten
ist das ganz ganz großes vor allem für
uns aus Waghäusel ist es was ganz ganz
tolles ja vor allem weil ich ja so mit
rezeptvideos gestartet bin und mir war
immer wichtig das rezeptvideos schön
aufgebaut sind dass ihr Kochen und
Backen lernt dass ihr Hintergrundwissen
bekommt über Zutaten über die Herkunft
und ich finde an der Art und Weise der
Videos hat sich gar nichts geändert oder
an der Message der Videos hat sich
einfach über die Jahre hinweg die
Qualität verbessert ich habe mich finde
ich so ein Stück weit optimiert ich bin
lockerer geworden ich stehe zu dem was
ich mache ich ich habe irgendwie keine
Angst mehr vor der Kamera ich denke mir
so hauptsache ich habe Spaß und dann hat
jeder Spaß und irgendwie macht mir alles
Spaß und was ich tatsächlich so ein
bisschen Beobachter auf sozialen
Plattform wenn man das mal so kurz
bisschen kritisch betrachten dürfen ich
meine wir haben auch zwei Töchter
natürlich hat Samira mittlerweile ein
Handy seit sehr auf der weiterführenden
Schule ist und auch die Ella hat jetzt
ein iPad bekommen
eins wo ich einfach einstellen kann
bildschirmzeit sie hat gewisse lern Apps
drauf die sie machen kann und natürlich
darf sie auch ein bisschen Medien
konsumieren aber ich bin da echt ich bin
da so ein Spießer ich bin da so streng
weil ich einfach finde dass man Kinder
nach wie vor nicht
Unruhe gefehlt hat einfach Mädchen
aussetzen darf weil ich finde das
mittlerweile soziale Medien da ich will
jetzt echt nicht haten aber ich will
auch einfach sagen allein schon tiktok
was dafür Videos drin sind was dafür
Content online geht der ungefil ist
Gewalt Hass reden Mobbing auf Youtube
muss ich sagen auch teilweise schon
extrem was da in den Trends ist und ich
finde das hat sich so ein bisschen in so
eine Richtung entwickelt so hauptsache
billig produziert jeder hat ein Handy
jeder kann was hochladen und ich wünsche
mir tatsächlich sehr dass wir da
Menschen vor die Kamera treten die sagen
sie wollen einfach ein bisschen
zumindest mal ein bisschen wieder das
Niveau heben und sagen hey wenn ich
schon gemacht habe und macht mal nichts
im Sinne von Reichweite dann nutze ich
meine Reichweite und mach einfach was
gescheites ich will doch keine Videos
sehen in den Menschen nur noch geprankt
und bloßgestellt werden ich will keine
Videos sehen in denen irgendwelche
Nacktheiten bloßgestellt werden ich will
einfach mal wieder coolen Content sehen
Menschen wie wie Julien BAM der das
immer gemacht hat der hat einfach coolen
Content macht da habe ich gesagt Mensch
meine Kinder die dürfen das Anschauen
und ich finde das sollten wir einfach
alle so ein bisschen was dafür tun dass
die Menschheit nicht verblödet ja der
Kopf ist nur noch da und man hängt nur
noch das da weil ich finde das Content
immer kürzer wird und ich will meine
langen Videos nicht aufgeben ich will
meine langen 10 15 und wir reden
trotzdem 15 Minuten Youtube Kochvideos
ich will die nicht aufgeben nur weil
irgendwie Kochvideos mittlerweile nur
noch aus 15 oder 20 Sekunden bestehen
ich finde da geht so viel
Hintergrundwissen verloren und es ist so
viel Zeit die draufgeht für unnützes ja
passt auch auf jeden Fall ganz wichtig
passt da auf es gibt coole Sachen es
gibt so kreative Sachen und auch auf tik
tok gibt es coolen kreativen tollen
Content da gibt es tänzel die ich auch
gerne mal mitmache es gibt einfach
schöne Sachen es gibt trendige Dinge die
cool sind da haben wir auch einige
mitgemacht dieses Jahr und das ist dann
auch schön weil ich in der Schule das
war richtig gut 2 Millionen oder
das war das war cool weil da haben wir
uns alle irgendwie hat sich jeder anders
verkleidet und dann hier
hahaha
4 oder 5 mal aufgenommen bis alle mal
einigermaßen synchron waren
was für ein Highlight war bitte diese
Aktion oh ja ich weiß auch oh mein Gott
ja wir machen nur kurz ein Video
da kann ich mich sehr gut drinnen
ganz kurz was haben wir gesagt wie lange
brauchen wir denn
ein Video komm wir machen auch mal den
Trend mal nach ja oder hat es im Prinzip
drei Stunden gedauert alles eingespielt
war das ist halt alles passt die Tänze
mit dem Konfetti mit dem Laubbläser der
auch noch was das war echt super lustig
aber das hat sich schon so richtig sexy
gemacht
[Gelächter]
haben wir uns den ganzen Tag Gedanken
gemacht was wir tanzen ja wieder
eigentlich immer nur getanzt alle Leute
denken ich habe nur getanzt ich wurde zu
Hause die ganze Zeit ausgedacht weil ich
nicht lach
gesagt wir sollen nicht schlafen
ohne zu lachen ich soll ich sollte nicht
lachen
im Handy
und am Ende durfte
das war seine Aufgabe jeder hat seinen
Spezial
[Applaus]
jeden Tag die gleichen Mist
ich war ja schon immer deine Königin
aber dieses Jahr wurde ich auch noch
Shopping oh mein Gott ja wir waren bei
Shopping Queen mal in Hamburg das war
eine tolle Sendung und du hast sie
gewonnen ja und es ist solche Formate wo
ich jetzt nicht unbedingt dabei sein
wollte aber was war hingegangen ich muss
sagen im Endeffekt wenn wir jetzt mal
live sehen und es ist wirklich kein Fake
man denkt ja immer das ist alles gefaked
und so ich muss ehrlich sagen ich hatte
die persönliche Erfahrung nicht damit
ich weiß nicht ob jemand die Erfahrung
hatte aber ich fand es war eine
authentische Sendung war richtig lustig
du hast sie gewonnen ähm
Guido ist ein riesen äh Fan von dir hat
er jedes Mal gesagt und es ist du hast
sie gewonnen es war eine tolle
Geschichte wir haben tolle Menschen
kennengelernt es war Hamburg haben
gelegt eine ganze Kreuzung lang gelegt
Polizisten kam
einfach genial eine ganz ganz Fernseher
Erfahrung aber ist natürlich genau wie
es läuft der musst du nichts erzählen
aber das ist so gut aus ehrlich ich will
die Nummer heiraten ja guck mal die
Bäume und dann was könnte man noch dazu
machen da passt schön wenn ich noch
einen Vorschlag machen darf das ist
Campen das ist Campen
also bisher läuft richtig gut wir waren
jetzt gerade in einem Laden und ich habe
eigentlich ein komplettes Outfit
gefunden weil sie nämlich in Hamburg
beim Goldeck Shop ja wir sind jetzt
gerade beim Styling und hier ist meine
Pediküre heute wunderschön
[Musik]
aber das wird dich das letzte Mal sein
dass ihr
mich im Fernsehen gesehen habt darf ich
das vielleicht sagen ja es ist für mich
stolz
da bin ich stolz drauf und zwar werde
ich dieses Jahr mit dem Günni zusammen
bei den Öffentlich-Rechtlichen eine
eigene TV-Sendung haben
[Applaus]
wie das abgelaufen ist da ist ein Sender
gekommen von den öffentlich-rechtlichen
hat gesagt wir würden gern die Sally
haben mit ihr eine coole Sendung machen
und das haben einfach gesagt okay die
sally hat leider keine Zeit das geht
einfach nicht dann haben die dann gesagt
okay dann mach doch du einfach und alles
okay alles klar jetzt hat sie und ich
wir bekommen eine eigene TV Sendung was
ganz ganz tolle ist dann werden zehn
Folgen kommen um uns Handwerken eine
ganz tolle Geschichte also uns bringen
Leute irgendwie Sachen ich darf so nicht
richtig sagen aber hier so stolz drauf
das heißt Günni und ich werden ganz ganz
tolle Sendung machen und euch jeder
zeigen ich bin sehr stolz auf euch ja es
ist wirklich jetzt machen
ich werde mich von dir abkuppeln
sozusagen aus dem Ei geschlüpft ja wir
machen uns eigen
und das tolle ist aus Waghäusel heraus
und es ist so glaube ich so stolz drauf
dass wir sagen können wir machen es von
zu Hause aus also eine ganz tolle
Sendung freut euch aufs Heimwerken freut
Euch auf ToolTime was verraten ja ein
Geheimnis was eigentlich war es euer
Bewährungshelfer der das eingetütet hat
ah okay
Heinz er hat Doku sozusagen Liebe
Freundschaft und äh Dinge zusammenhalten
nein ja
ich wollte gerade umarmen aber ich habe
gehört dass ab 20 cm springen Milben
deswegen nicht so Nagy und wir freuen
uns richtig drauf auf das Team TV Team
und ja habe ich auch drauf sei ehrlich
aber ehrlich du kannst die Wahrheit
sagen das will ich ausgestrahlt ja ich
freue mich
ich werde gezwungen das zu sagen
eine große Signierstunde hatten wir auch
endlich im Q6 Q7 wir haben ja im Jahr
2020 dort unseren Flagshipstore eröffnet
der war ja damals geplant für den 4.4
und dann kam mir aber im März die
Pandemie und die ganze Welt hat sich
verändert und wir wussten nicht können
wir überhaupt öffnen oder nicht und dann
ging aber wir können ja gar nicht mehr
zurück denn der ganze Laden war ja schon
fertig designt und eingerichtet also
haben wir die Zeit genutzt damals in
eingerichtet aber wir hatten noch nie
bis heute nicht wir hatten noch keine
offizielle Eröffnung wir mussten still
und leise öffnen und mir hat das Herz
geblutet weil wir so viel Herzblut auch
reingesteckt haben und so viel Arbeit
und dieser Shop eigentlich immer nur
leise öffnen durfte wir hatten sechs
Monate geschlossen mein Team haben wir
teilweise mit nach Waghäusel genommen
damit da eben auch keiner zu kurz kommt
und arbeitslos wird aber unser Job dort
der ist uns ganz wichtig wir haben ganz
ganz tolle Mitarbeiter die sind wirklich
die sind immer weg das ist Feedback von
Zuschauern ist unglaublich also noch mal
ganz ganz ganz ganz ganz
lieben Dank an die an die Menschen in
Mannheim die Mitten zusammen den Shop
betreiben und uns helfen gegenseitig es
ist so viel Dankeschön ihr macht das
ganz toll wir sind richtig stolz auf
Euch und weil das Signierstunde da ist
jeder so noch mal als Team enger
zusammengewachsen
[Musik]
ich bin so glücklich dass ihr alle da
seid ich habe heute nacht echt nicht gut
geschlafen ich habe gedacht das kommt
bestimmt keiner ich weiß das auch ganz
viele von ganz weit weg sind und viele
viele Stunden
vielen Dank ich hoffe ihr habt heute
einen ganz schönen Tag freue mich
richtig
endlich wieder Menschen treffen und die
sind alle für mich da das ist richtig
süß ich habe meinen meine Freudentränen
Weg gelächelt falls ihr es gemerkt habt
okay dann können wir starten
[Musik]
aus ganz Deutschland in die nehmen sich
da jede da ist ja kein Weg zu weit da
waren welche aus Berlin aus Österreich
waren Leute da also das ist echt krass
und die haben mir dann auch teilweise
voll lange gewartet richtig schön auch
das ist so das ist so überwältigend
kannst du gar nicht glauben aber da
waren so viele Menschen und die waren
alle das waren alles so liebe und nette
Menschen und die hatten alles so viel
Geduld auch beim Warten also die Leute
standen das so lang und wir haben die
dann mit Essen und Trinken versorgt der
Shop in Mannheim und der mir die Backen
ja dann immer schon paar Tage vorher
waren dass jeder versorgt ist und
Trinken bekommen also den Leuten soll
dann auch nicht schlecht gehen
und dann waren wir auch das erste mal
wieder richtig auf Messe und ich war oh
mein Gott ich war so aufgeregt ich weiß
doch ich war hinter dieser Tür das war
auf der IFA mit Bosch und ich war hinter
dieser Tür und ich war tagelang
aufgeregt und konnte nicht schlafen weil
ich gesagt habe WoW das letzte Mal war
2019 und zwar vor der Pandemie und ich
finde die Pandemie hat schon die Welt
sehr verändert viele Menschen verändert
viele Menschen kamen gar nicht klar
damit andere Menschen haben sich
weiterentwickelt Firmen haben sich
weiterentwickelt es haben sich neue
Technologien irgendwie ergeben und das
Leben hat sich verändert also sagen es
gibt viele die jetzt sagen wow ich muss
gar nicht mehr von A nach B reisen ich
kann online Meetings machen was sich
mega anbietet viel der Umwelt kommt oder
auch viel Zeit spart aber es gibt
natürlich auch Dinge die kann man nicht
online machen und das sind so diese
persönlichen privaten schönen Momente
mit euch zum Beispiel und ich habe das
so vermisst aber ich sag so ich war so
aufgeregt ich dachte einfach es kommen
niemand es kommen niemand diese Halle
bleibt leer und ich glaube die Zeit ist
vorbei dass Menschen kommen und eine
Halle ausfüllen und jeder hat Angst und
keiner will und da stand ich dahinter
und ich hatte sogar Gänsehaut und dann
warten
ich hoffe
[Musik]
heiß
so schnell wie wir sind Zeitraffer
ich bin der Zeitraffer
die IFA bauen Highlight das war der
Wahnsinns erstmal das bei so einem
großen Event dabei war oder bei einer
Messe da war die Hölle los wenn wir dann
noch im ganzen Stress die goodybags
gepackt haben raus zack zack zack zack
zack zack zack zack zack zack zack zack
zack geholfen
die Mitarbeiter auch vor Ort 300
[Gelächter]
man hätte man hätte
und dann war so lustig weil wir hatten
dann so ein Wohnwagen für Sie so eine
ganz kleinen Video gesehen ja und dann
wie sie wie sie da bin ich einmal zu
denen zu Julia und ihr rein weil die
Julia bei ihr ja Make-up gemacht und ich
ziehe rein und dann sitzt sie einfach da
auf der auf diesen auf diesen Bett und
schreibt schon mal vor
es stehen schon sehr viele um die Küche
rum zehn kann man Kaffee trinken
ich sag doch immer wenn nur zehn komm
gehe ich mit den Kaffee trinken nein das
sind mehr als Freunde ja
also es hat noch nicht das ist noch
nicht zu Ende da kommen bestimmt noch
ein paar ja aber was heißt voll voll
oder noch nicht so toll aber
schon losgeht ja
sie nutzt jede Minute für Fans aus und
wirklich dann jedem Auto kam auch zu
geben und wirklich sie macht's auch mit
Leidenschaft ist nicht so dass einfach
Leidenschaft für jeden Autogramm weil
die Leute kommen extra für Sie und das
tut sie sehr sehr wertschätzen
[Musik]
ich freue mich wenn ihr zu sein und ich
freue mich dass ihr alle gekommen seid
[Musik]
ihr schon platt es waren schon
pickelbacke
wieder
wirklich
wie viele Fans da auch kommen wie krass
das wirklich ist jeden stand und über
alles so ein bisschen was los klar die
Messe war voll aber dann bei Sallys
stand bei Sallys Show
das war gigantisch also wirklich wie die
alle da gestanden haben so alle gewartet
haben auf Sally dann kam sie raus wie
sie geschrien haben ganze Eve aber
einfach voll das war bei den ganzen
Herstellern es ging rum jeder hat
darüber gesprochen die ganze Halle ist
da voll was ist da los und es war
wirklich abartig und die haben die
mussten die Shows danach noch absagen
weil so voll war es war einfach krass
die Fahne ist einfach alles super
[Musik]
dieses Jahr waren wir natürlich auch
wieder in der Türkei auf Reisen war auch
eine schöne Reise mit dem Team genau
ja also erstens
einmal auf dem Lavendelfeld genau
keramikflaschen
genau
habe ich noch was vergessen und es sind
so wir freuen uns jedes Jahr wir haben
immer eine große Türkei Reise jedes Jahr
und die geht dann über eine Woche immer
sogar zehn Tage ich habe diese damals
sogar 10 Tage wir waren in der Arbeit
Schatz und wir waren mit dem gesamten
Team also ein großes Thema 12 oder 13
Leute waren mir und haben dann einfach
Menschen gezeigt Menschen Emotionen
keine Politik politisches ekliges ist
wirklich das ist was ganz ganz ekliges
sondern Menschen gezeigt und zwar wie
gesagt leben was sie da tun was sie
bewerkstelligen was sind tolle Arbeit
leisten und da waren wir in Yozgat wir
haben ihn Lavendelfeldern und da war so
eine Kooperation von Frauen die sich zum
Ziel gemacht haben ihr Leben
selbstständig in die Hand zu nehmen und
dadurch haben wir ja die Handcremes
gemacht die man essen kann
die Seifen das war schon sehr sehr schön
das war eine tolle Reise die Kinder
durften auch mit und haben es miterlebt
es war die Bilder noch sehen dann kommen
es war ganz ganz toll gedreht es war
einfach nur sehr sehr emotional
unglaublich
ja
[Musik]
Lavendel hat glaube ich echt so mit die
schönsten Bilder aus den ganzen Videos
jetzt gehabt wir sind ja quer durch die
Türkei und das Ding ist wir waren ja die
ganze Zeit unterwegs was man bei den
Videos halt nie sieht wir waren ja von
morgens und acht ging's los so ne da
haben wir kurz gefrühstückt und dann
ging es schon direkt los weil wir die
Sonne gebraucht haben wir haben tolle
Bilder gebraucht Videos
Urlaub machen ja da unterstützt die
schon echt coole Projekt muss ich sagen
ich komme aus Gänsehaut guck mal die
Bilder sind halt auch wunderschön ich
meine ihr habt da tolle Sachen gedreht
ihr Vater eine lange Zeit und habe ganz
viel eingefangen also ich finde den
Schnitt super schön die Bilder super
schön
wie wir uns immer gestritten
die besten Stories sieht das beste Video
und sie die besten Fotos jetzt streitet
euch
eine Frage meine Güte diese Videos aus
der Türkei anschaut wo wir jedes Jahr
sind es ist einfach schön es ist einfach
nur schön die ganzen Bilder die ganzen
moods wie die gedreht sind das ist
wirklich Netflix das ist schon wirklich
unglaublich und es kommt auch dazu noch
ein schöner großer Flock denn wir haben
ja nicht nur die vier Einzel Videos
gedreht sondern auch einfach einen Vlog
von unserer Türkei Reise gedreht da
sieht man auch immer so ein bisschen den
Blick hinter die Kulissen des Team was
dann auch immer gezeigt wird also der
flog der ist wirklich auch richtig schön
ich glaube den sollten wir auch 20:15
Uhr hochladen weil das ist so ein Blog
wo man sagt okay jetzt schaut euch
Popcorn und Getränke setzt euch hin und
genießt einfach das ist das wird schon
ziemlich cool
was hast du vor das wollen wir einfach
raus
ach Gott
der König in der Türkei das war so
witzig gell
ich schon gerne in der Türkei
[Musik]
freut ihr euch auf den ganzen Knoblauch
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ja und dann gab es dieses Jahr auch eine
Reise die ich ohne dich angetreten bin
weil du kein Visum hattest ich war in
London auf dem borromarket das sind ganz
ganz toller food market wir waren dann
in heavens bei Kenwood wurden eingeladen
durften uns die ähm die den Betrieb dort
anschauen das Team kennenlernen und es
war echt eine schöne Reise und das
schönste an dem Video fand ich dass du
mal gezeigt hast wie viel Kraft diese
Küchenmaschine hat wie das Ding anzieht
also wie man im Auto benutzen jede
geredet jede Rede von diesem Video
gerade über diese Szene ja vor allem
weil ich dachte das wäre irgendwie
gefaked gewesen aber nein die haben
einfach vorne an der Rührschüssel
ausgeschnitten und dann so eine Kordel
also eine starke Seil an die Maschine
haben dem ich durfte die Maschine
anmachen und dann zieht die einfach
diesen diesen
[Musik]
Maschine
das ist so cool ich meine eigentlich ist
es einfach nur eine Küchenmaschine die
hat hier gerade einen Wagen gezogen
jetzt wird auch einiges klar warum so
gut so gut Hefeteige nudelteige und
alles andere knetet oder das hat man
echt noch nicht gesehen cool
das macht den halt Spaß ja den Jungs aus
dem Ingenieurbüro dann so Spaß dran
[Musik]
wenn ich nicht so gerne kochen und
backen würde ich sag's dir ich hätte nur
noch ein katzenkanal
[Musik]
unglaublich
schneiden ich habe ein bisschen was
[Musik]
aber ich möchte nicht mehr missen also
ich möchte kein Leben mehr ohne Katze
das war so süß wie mal Kindergeburtstag
war von Ella ja ich streichel dich
weiter mein Schatz und dann lag draußen
und toter Vogel vom Fenster und ich habe
gesagt zu den Kindern oh der ist
bestimmt gegen die Scheibe geflogen und
dann gestorben da sagt das eine Kind so
weil ich so fünf Jahre so richtig
klugscheiße nein da liegt da liegen ganz
viele Väter das war bestimmt eine Woche
Katzen und dann habe ich gesagt nein
unsere Katzen sind voll süß die machen
sowas nicht guckst du dir an die Muffin
die macht doch sowas nicht und dann habe
ich hat sie gesagt doch das gegen die
Scheibe geflogen das war auch vor
Raubtier und
und dann komme ich nach hause habe so
den hör auf damit machen
mein Wollpulli nein
komm her
liebt die Mama einfach okay
zu machen
jedenfalls bin ich dann rein und habe
den Kindern richtig schön verklickern
können dass unsere Katzen so lieb sind
und keiner Fliege was so leide tun und
da sitzt Muffin drin putzt sich ihre
Pfoten und die ganzen Vogel
also unsere Katzen greifen auf dem
Postboten ne weil ich liebe das mit ihr
zu kämpfen also ich mag das also
wirklich
bei unserem zwei Katzen ja die töten
alles
[Gelächter]
hör auf mach jetzt nicht hier sonst
bring mich nach hinten an naja
jedenfalls war dieses Jahr haben wir
dich ja auch überrascht und haben Schlag
den Murat gespielt
ich verstehe es ihr noch nicht warum die
das gemacht haben also so eine tolle
Firma weil du 40 Jahre alt wurdest und
wir uns überlegt haben wie wir dich
überraschen können und da habt ihr schon
alles besitzen und jedes Kärcher Modell
besitzt dachte nein nein mir fehlt noch
eine V6 oh ja dachten wir wir
überraschen dich und äh veräppeln dich
denn niemand ist ja eigentlich so deine
Ideen der Firma der immer alle veräppelt
der alle auf den Armen nimmt der sich
für alle lustig macht und immer lustig
ist dann haben wir umgedreht und haben
ihn mal entführt dahin das war genial
diese Frage und eigentlich wollten wir
ihn fertig machen aber er hat uns wieder
fertig ja einer der schönsten Tage
meines Lebens ich dachte so der Typ ist
krank du bist einfach krank du bist ein
richtiger Nerd was Kälte betrifft schon
durch jedes Gerät am Geräusch erkannt
der philipp hat auswendig gelernt
sowas auch macht der nicht gedacht guck
mal jetzt Philipp aussieht das sieht aus
wie ein haarwachstudentin jedes Student
versteht das sieht aus wie
Schwiegermutters Liebling der versteht
keiner hier nicht wie kann man
putzgeräte an ihrem Geräusche du hast
sogar erkannt dass da kein Wasser es
gibt sogar Menschen die sich in
Flugzeuge verlieben und ich habe mich
einfach verliebt ja ist aber so wenn ich
höre vom vom Geräusche das ist der mit
der mit der mit der Rundung ist 100%
Gesichter
könnte es vielleicht sein dass der wd3
Batterie ist
Prozent das weiß ich das ist der FC
Sieber und zwar habe ich gerade gemerkt
dass die Rolle nicht genug Wasser hat
und deswegen tut am Anfang immer kurz
stoppen 100% FC 7 wenn das nicht der fc7
ist lasse ich mich Scheide 100%
[Musik]
dieses Jahr waren wir auch wieder im
Europapark zum welthospiztag und das ist
für mich immer so eine Ereignis das
markiere ich mir immer im Kalender da
weiß ich immer an dem Tag geh meinen
Europapark besuchen dort alle Kinder die
dabei sind mit dem Bundesverband
Kinderhospiz das immer so schön so viele
Kinder zu sehen die dann glücklich sind
Familien die dabei sind Kinder die
sowieso schon schwer haben es gibt ja in
Deutschland über 50.000 Kinder die
unheilbar krank sind und ich glaube wenn
du was heißt ich glaube ich weiß wenn du
als Familie die Diagnose bekommst dass
dein Kind
nie erwachsen wird dann ist es echt so
als der nämlich eines der schlimmsten
ist das schlimmste was man überhaupt
erleben kann und deswegen unterstützen
wir da den Bundesverband und sind da
immer
engagiert mit dabei
und für mich ist immer schön weil der
Tag ist so dass da Europapark immer alle
Kinder einlädt die bekommt dann alle
kostenlosen Eintritt ist immer ein
schönes Event und da kann man immer den
Kindern und den Familien zumindest einen
Tag schenken den sie schön verbringen
können und einfach mehrere Krankheit
vergessen
ja und alles in allem muss ich sagen
dass wir schon immer sehr professionell
unterwegs sind und es läuft nie was
schief
aber das ist genau das was es alles
ausmacht dass man manche Sachen nicht
mit dem auch mal nicht mit dem nötigen
Ernst nimmt also wirklich dass man Spaß
bei der Sache dass man immer lacht dass
man glücklich ist ja du kannst wirklich
lachen
und er erkennt ob sie fertig sind
das ist mir gerade eingefallen deswegen
fressen
Haut das Video weg dann gehe ich mich
schneller Beziehung mein Gott
okay ich kann wieder
wirklich auf die
dancing
[Musik]
was haben wir denn letzte Woche gemacht
wir haben letzte Woche
gerade das Thema Gießen ist ja sehr
wichtig ihr habt ja drei Möglichkeiten
zum Gießen verdammte jetzt brauche ich
hier den
die muss erst mich kennenlernen
mein kleiner grüner
GT sich noch um hier
und ich sag's jetzt voll laufen da kann
man reich übernehmen keine Haftung
ich übernehme keine Haftung wenn Anna
sich hier verletzt
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
Spaß Spaß
perfekt
[Musik]
aus dem topshot ja ja und doch
supermaus
dieses Jahr hatten wir auch einige
Besucher bei zu Gast bei Sally hast du
gerade gegessen
[Musik]
würde würde ich das nicht schaffen außer
ich muss mir das Umfeld bauen aber ich
glaube wenn man Ziele für sich selbst
gesetzt hat dann kann man sie schon
realistisch naja klar sind deine Träume
ja nicht ne also
[Musik]
brauchen dafür daheim
brauchen wir Öl ne so okay Moment hier
hier steht drin wie man Gulasch macht
und hier steht drin wie meine Donauwelle
macht das braucht man auch und das
brauchen wir auf jeden Fall 29,90 die
hat doch ein Rad ab das habe ich getan
was habe ich getan okay jetzt hast du
gewonnen jetzt darfst du tatsächlich
alles mitnehmen Mensch super danke
bitte schön gerne
wiedersehen
[Applaus]
auf jeden Fall
[Musik]
hätte doch einfach sagen können macht
die Augen zu für was brauche ich so eine
Taucherbrille meine Nase kommt nicht
dran
[Applaus]
Martin
[Musik]
wir hatten echt zu wenige zu Gast bei
dieses Jahr ja stimmt mehr machen
ja okay ja und ansonsten
[Musik]
waren großes Projekt von uns dieser der
Adventskalender
an die Grenzen gebracht aber ich finde
es war ein sehr schöner Adventskalender
für den ich mir echt den Kopf mehr als
sehr intensiv zerbrochen habe und das
Feedback von euch bestätigt das auch ja
nach 24 Stunden war der komplett
ausverkauft und hat mich nicht wenig
aber es war einfach ausverkauft und dann
war aber sowas von von wie soll ich
seine Enttäuschung da dass wir irgendwie
noch probiert haben noch mehr
Adventskalender
für sozusagen hinbekommen und es war
richtig schönes Jahr für uns war ein
großes privates Thema tatsächlich das
Ella eigentlich geschult wurde wir haben
jetzt zwei Schulkinder und ich muss
sagen dass es mir echt gut damit geht
also eigentlich so emotional ich war
schon ein bisschen fix und fertig weil
mein kleines Kindergartenkind jetzt auch
ein Schulkind ist und jetzt werden beide
großen sieben und zwölf aber es läuft
super toi toi toi Ella hat eine tolle
Lehrerin tolle Klasse und sie ist auch
echt gerne ein Schulkind langweilig dich
tut mir leid es ist einfach gekommen
dieses Jahr war ja auch so
trendmäßig habe ich gemacht die Comic
Torte
die Minions Torte oh ja die Minions das
war richtig cool es war zum Kinofilm zum
Kinostart von den Minions ich liebe so
filmtoppen bei dir da pflege ich mir
total aus ja ich liebe ich liebe auch
viel im Torten weil ich da echt mega
kreativ sein kann
sag's mir anders
oh Gott der erste April diese
Aprilscherz
das macht er nicht mehr gell April
Schatz macht er nicht mehr mit mir oder
da haben sie da haben sie da haben sie
sich irgendwie keine Ahnung wie das
zusammengewuschelt wurde am Ende hieß es
die SD-Karten sind formatiert und da war
das eine Material drauf und ich habe den
Tag vorher vier Stunden mit dieser Mini
Nagelschere dieses nifflerfeld
geschnitten und dann haben die sich da
drüben im Valley versammelt das ganze
Team und ich sollte dahin und ich hatte
eh keine Zeit und war Musical von den
Kindern und zwar so ein wer war und ich
dachte sowas ich stelle jetzt hier los
und ich bin echt ein geduldiger Mensch
oder steht da der Maurice steht Maurice
einfach da mit einer Kamera in dem
leeren Büro und ich frage wo sind die
ganzen Menschen hin wo arbeiten denn
alle das ist schon heute
loser krank die krank der krank alle
waren weg und ich dachte mir sowas
stimmt heute nicht in diesem Unternehmen
Leute ich muss noch meine Motivtorte
fertig machen und ich muss noch auf
Musical und habe gerade 500 Cupcakes im
Backofen meine Kinder haben auftritt und
ich war so fertig ich dachte mir so was
stimmt hier nicht oder steht da hat eine
Kamera in der Hand filmt mich und hat
eine Perücke auf wieso eine Frau dann
habe ich gesagt stimmt nicht mit dir was
ist denn los mit dir und dann haben sie
sich alle versammelt im Valley unten und
haben sich als Sally und Murat
verkleidet dann habe ich mir gedacht
echt jetzt echt jetzt haben wir jetzt
haben wir jetzt echt Zeit für ein
studentenfehler ich habe gedacht wie wie
macht so ein Studentenfilm und ich habe
das nicht verstanden dass sie gesagt
haben april April
ich dachte eben kurz der Maurice hat
einen Fetisch
[Gelächter]
oh macht sowas echt nicht mehr echt gut
gesagt nein
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
ich war schon geduldig
ich habe nichts mehr verstanden ich war
richtig in so einer in so einer
Parallelwelt naja es war echt süß
gedacht von meinem Team die hatten sich
alle Paare bestellt Perücken jeder war
angezogen wieder Murat das war schon
goldig aber übertreib es nicht
[Musik]
was haben wir gewünscht okay ja
und dann haben wir mit unserem Team
gemeinsam das Jahr beendet mit einer
schönen Weihnachtsfeier im Europapark
ist für uns gerade mal eine Stunde 20
Minuten entfernt also sind richtig gerne
und da gehen wir gerne und ich hoffe
dass wir dieses Jahr wieder mit hingehen
aber im Sommer es war wirklich kalt weil
ich bin ich bin die Achterbahn gefahren
als ein Zapfen aber ich fand es schön in
der Kälte da gab es einen Punsch
Glühwein ich finde der Weihnachtszeit
ist der Europapark so richtig so winter
wonderland ich bin gerne dort es ist
immer schön wir hatten mega viel Spaß
und jeder war dabei tut gut
wir müssen alle Parks in ganz
Deutschland besuchen
[Musik]
ich habe gesagt
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich muss aber auch sagen dass ich gegen
Ende des Jahres habe ich hat mit der
muraten ziemlich Schrecken eingejagt ich
mir auch ich war da nämlich also ich
habe ja immer über seinen Schnarchen
geschimpft weil
ich
glaube das ist voll bei voll vielen
Menschen so dass sie irgendwann
getrennten Betten schlafen weil der Mann
anscheinend Schnarchen die Frau nicht
ich wollte eigentlich auch mal sagen
auch in der Öffentlichkeit zu Schnarch
übrigens auch mein Handy aufnehmen wie
du schneiden
ehrlich ja ich weiß es doch ohne Spaß
wenn ich so meine verstopfte Nase haben
sorry aber dass ich zu den Nachbarn aus
dem Fenster raus rufe ja ich kriege das
den Griff macht euch keine Sorgen ja nur
auf jeden Fall ich habe echt ich habe
echt geschnarcht aber ich hatte dann
irgendwann nicht mehr so das Gefühl
dafür weil ich meine immer geschneit
aber nicht so schlimm da dachte ich mir
so versteife ich mich da jetzt drauf
oder hat er irgendwas und dann hat man
sie auch an seiner Stimme gehört dass
seine Stimm
meine Stimme hat sich so schleimig so
als hätte ich eine Blase im Hals genau
und das war jetzt wirklich überein du
bist eineinhalb Monate und ich habe halt
keine Zeit gab es weil ich war einfach
dauern dann irgendwas basteln und Werken
im Günni zusammen oder ist mir wirklich
die rechte Seite im Nacken entlang und
am Rücken entlang habe ich so wie als
hätte ich den steifen Nacken die ganze
Zeit ja stimmt du bist immer so gelaufen
genau und dann kam ein Interview oder
halt nicht Videoaufnahmen die
Videosequenz wurde der Eco bei uns war
als er mit uns ein Interview geführt hat
stimmt ein Podcast
zuschauen Bild gemacht und hat gesagt
hey irgendwas mit einem Hals stimmt
nicht und dann da ich irgendwas und dann
habe ich da wirklich hingefasst und habe
gemerkt als im Grünen Gerät hey das
stimmt was ich irgendwas also wie so ein
Ball und dann bin ich zum Arzt und hat
der Arzt dann festgestellt dass ich eine
süße habe da stand der vor mir und guckt
mich an mit so richtig Training auf
Augen und sagt Schatz guck mal mein Hals
und dann habe ich gesagt
mal dahin
und habe ich richtig Angst der kriegt
weil ich dann nicht wusste was der da
hat und dann war es halt eine krasse
Zyste und dann waren
7 cm groß und das Problem ist man wusste
jetzt nicht wie weit sie noch nach
hinten geht und hat natürlich einen
Schock und es war dieser Moment wo man
eigentlich aus den Filmen kennt wenn
jemand eine böse Krankheit bekommt und
das dann ganz schlimm wird und so haben
wir uns in dem Moment gefühlt und dann
habe ich einfach gemerkt dass dass sie
sofort zum Arzt gehen musste danach
geschaut er hat gesagt
Ultraschall gemacht genau und habe dann
Termin beim Arzt bekommen es war eine
Uniklinik in Heidelberg und da wurde
dann raus gemacht und zwar Gott sind nur
züchte und ein Teil der Schilddrüse war
wurde weggemacht das ist aber jetzt
nicht schlimmes und zwar auch alles gut
aber alles super aber ich Glück gehabt
aber das hat mir dann wieder gezeigt hey
wie immer ihr wisst wie sich ich sagte
man merkt oftmals im Leben nicht dass
das Leben endlich ist man denkt immer es
geht immer weiter es geht weiter und ja
zu ja und das hat auch da zu der Zeit
das war so ein paar Tage da war er auch
ziemlich seltsam drauf muss man dazu
sagen also da habe ich ja immer gesagt
ich was will ich mir was sagen hat der
Arzt doch was anderes gesagt weil er so
krass nachdenklich dann war also ich
habe das schon ziemlich gemerkt und da
es hat mir wieder mal wieder so ein so
ein Ding gegeben ein schussform Bug hey
das Leben ist endlich auch auch das
Leben von deiner Familie ist endlich
auch von deinen Freunden ist endlich und
genieße es einfach etwas mehr und äh das
heißt
türkisch also so kleine so kleine Dinge
wir waren einfach vor großen Dingen ja
so kleine schrecken wir waren nicht vor
großen
Leben natürlich auch dass er das auch
immer wieder euch vor die Augen führt
dass das Leben endlich ist und das wird
gar nicht leben kann als wäre es jeden
Tag der letzte Tag ist es schon klar
aber dass man sagt was ist wichtig im
Leben und es sind wirklich Familie und
Freunde und soziale Kontakte nicht Geld
nicht ruhen nicht Erfolg sondern
wirklich die sozialen Kontakten
die muss man wirklich oft pflegen das
ist wichtig nicht durch kurze
WhatsApp-Nachrichten so dass man sich
immer trifft zusammen was essen geht
zusammen etwas unternehmen und es ist
ganz ganz wichtig und das jetzt habe ich
hier eine riesen Narbe hier am Hals als
ich das ist okay es ist okay also es
geht der kompletten Hals als hätte ich
ihn ein Kampf gehabt oder sowas das
werde ich natürlich anderen erzählen
haben mir fehlt uns gerettet von einem
bösen Raubtier ja und mir fehlt jetzt
einfach ein Großteil der Schilddrüse ist
nicht schlecht es gibt Menschen die
leben auch ohne Hirn weiter ähm aber
wieso soll ich sagen ja Dinge die kommen
einfach so da weiß man bis heute nicht
woher aber ich finde als Mensch muss man
trotzdem immer dafür Sorge tragen dass
man gesund bleibt und wirklich aktiv was
dafür tut und gesund bleiben heißt für
mich nicht nur gut ernähren und Sport
sondern auch mental gesund bleiben das
heißt sich nicht so sehr stressen lassen
das muss ich z.B ein bisschen
viel cooler werden mein Gott dann ist es
jetzt halt so und es sind auch so
Vorsätze wie nächstes Jahr noch mal ich
weiß wann ich das ja auch schon der
Vorsatz mehr Zeit mit der Familie sind
zu nehmen ganz ganz wichtig weniger zu
machen war auch meine Vorsatz letztes
Jahr wir haben dieses Jahr wieder total
wieder total beschrieben übertrieben
muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen und einfach
mehr mit dir zu verbringen mit Mama und
Papa ja aber dieses Jahr machst du jetzt
schon mal was für dich mit deiner
Sendung mit das wird auch spaßig
an eurer Freundschaft ich mache dieses
Jahr auch was für mich äh ich darf nur
noch nicht erzählen aber ganz bald
erzähle ich da das wird für mich auch
ganz ganz schön und wird eine ganz ganz
tolle Zeit auf die ich mich sehr freue
zusammen und und tut euch nicht
gegenseitig mit negativen Nachrichten zu
ballern ganz ganz wichtig ihr könnt
viele Dinge gar nicht verändern jetzt
wenn in China jetzt nur Sack Reis Umfeld
dann fällt er um es kann passieren aber
du hast nicht verhindern können also tut
doch nicht gegenseitig mit mit negativen
Dingen zu ballern macht einfach mal wie
es Peter Lustig immer gesagt wird ein
Fernsehsendung gehabt Peter Lustig ich
weiß nicht ob ihr noch kennt und immer
nach der Sendung hat er gesagt und jetzt
schalte den Fernseher aus stimmt und ich
finde es immer so toll und das was ich
sagen möchte weniger Social Media
wirklich wirklich
kümmert euch um euch um eure Gesundheit
und eure körperlichen geistige
Gesundheit und einfach abschalten und
nicht immer den hier und den hier und
den hier ganz ganz wichtig er spricht zu
sich ja hast du gehört Ali mein bester
Kumpel ja das stimmt macht
Bilder von mir geschickt und lacht sich
tot noch nicht so gut ja ja
also wir freuen uns auf dieses Jahr wir
haben viele spannende Projekte vor da
könnt ihr euch wirklich drauf freuen und
ich freue mich auf ein schönes Jahr mit
Euch vielen vielen Dank immer für euer
Feedback für eure Rückmeldung tausend
Dank für die tollen Nachrichten für die
Treue für Vertrauen und ähm wir lieben
unseren Job wir lieben unsere Arbeit wir
werden auch in diesem Jahr viele änder
Frauen machen wie zum Beispiel die
Küchen umbauen hier auch bei uns im
Valley weil es einfach Zeit wird für
eine Tapetenwechsel Zeit für Optimierung
und Zeit für
wir machen einfach was ja
immer im Mandel bleiben das ist ganz
wichtig bleibt nicht stehen da wo ihr
seid entwickelt euch weiter und ab dem
nächsten Video geht es wieder mit
Rezepten weiter und falls ihr Wünsche
habt anregungen Kritik egal was schreibt
einfach in die Kommentare wir lesen
Kommentare wir beantworten Kommentare
wir versuchen auch fast alles zu
antworten auf alles geht nicht immer
aber es ist tatsächlich immer besser
einen Kommentar öffentlich zu schreiben
weil wir da immer durchscrollen
durchleiten kommentieren
Privatnachrichten gehen oftmals verloren
weil es einfach viel viel viel zu viele
sind das heißt wenn ihr wirklich
wichtige Anliegen habt dann schreibt sie
uns in die Kommentare und dann bemühen
wir uns auch immer alles mögliche von
euch zu lesen und euch dann auch wieder
Feedback zu geben also vielen Dank für
das Jahr 2022 jetzt starten wir mit dem
Jahr 2023 das wird toll wirklich also
motiviert euch selber ich sage euch eins
nach diesen drei schlimmen Jahren nicht
mehr ganz ganz sicher dass 2023 ein ganz
ganz tolles Jahr wird auch für euch
ja
über Silvester startet so geht es weiter
gell kannst du mir geben
so jetzt kleine tschüss
[Musik]